each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
you
for browsing through spatially
referenced breast cancer image databases
on this is joint work with Dave taloosh
who is one of my graduate students and
sort of a group of undergraduates as
well okay it's an introduction breast
cancer is one of the leading causes of
death and women and mammography is
currently the most cost effective method
for early detection of breast cancer
however there's a lot of false negatives
so it turns out between ten to thirty
percent of women with breast cancer have
negative mammograms in about two-thirds
of these cases that cancer is evident
about upon review now improving
computer-aided detection could reduce
false negatives and what we really want
to do is use this to increase the
effectiveness of radiologists and really
the goal is to avoid misdiagnosis now
it's well known that there are
alternative technologies and they could
perform better than mammography for
example MRI ultrasound and this could be
all both at detecting the cancer as well
as evaluating the malignancy you can
also vary on characteristics with a
patient for example the age the breast
density they all seem to be important
characteristics there's a lot of
different ways of attacking the problem
also some of the things something that
could be improved by some of our
techniques its use of teleradiology
where you would improve the access for
rural hospitals as well as things like
mammography vans which would also upload
images and get the diagnosis so all of
these real all these tasks could be
improved with a suitable medical image
database which is sort of what we were
trying to build but we the goal of our
building process is really to apply some
pictorial query specification methods
that we developed and so that's sort of
where the
I into the databases and so what we
built or we're actually building is
something called Archimedes and this
stance denotes an archive of medical
images what happened is that we got the
project and we had this class and
software engineering where we're
involving quite a few students and
building the database and doing these
things and they came up with a name and
I thought was not a bad name if you see
the poster next door it looked at you
know it's sort of catching and so that's
it now the goal is to help train or test
computer-aided diagnosis systems and we
provide the data and doctors analyses
for experiments and it actually stores
the cat analysis for comparisons as well
as well as feature sets for combination
comparison and enables you to combine
these feature sets now the database has
a capability of storing images from
multiple technologies such as the
mammograms MRI ultrasounds and it also
enables research into the effectiveness
of the usefulness of each technique
either for the screening or the
determination and what we want to do is
compare the techniques using images of
the same patients or similar sets of
patients as well as finding out how the
effectiveness of the techniques
correlates with these various
characteristics are mentioned before now
we'll use is web-based query tool to
access the data and will combine
low-level feature sets by creating these
new diagnosis criteria and what we want
to do of course is find similar cases
similar the current patient so improve
this diagnosis accuracy and this is
really all can also be done with the
database to determine percentage of
similar patients who had malignant
cancer or benign now what you know the
again these these techniques will be
used for these various aspects of it so
why cancer imaging can be difficult you
have a large amount
extraneous info the cancer area is the
most interesting and there are many
superfluous structures are similar to
the cancerous structures some examples
are ducks and breasts and as I said
before many false positives and false
negatives there is a high noise level
but in it the image quality is improving
pretty quick you know a lot so noise can
be less of an issue at times I'm not a
radiologist so other people can say much
more to this and we're really the thing
we're looking at again is the pictorial
queries specification which will get too
soon um okay so here's sort of an
example of some of the things that we've
done and again this is more of a
background in terms of mammogram it's
really an x-ray of the breast you have
four images are typically taken let's
say two for each breast from top and
side and the texture of the cancer is
similar to some of the normal tissue and
here for example is what a radiologist
okay show you know outlined in red and
the side view we see here these are
really side views or the left and right
breasts now the breast tissue is
compressed in the imaging process which
makes 3d reconstruction challenging but
it is done at times comparing images
helps in diagnosing the cancer and image
comparison again is necessary because
the cancers appearance is really very
similar than normal breast tissue so we
want to do is find the in the similar
image sets so here's sort of an example
again the and here we have these tiny
colored okay these tiny colored circles
they're really shaped features and here
you the radiologist if i can find that
big dark circle i'm terrible at this
amount oh do you see it anywhere well
yes anyway you can see it up there right
oops what did this to that'll teach me
to touch it okay now it should I got now
I guess you point with the I know that
alright so I'm not sure about that huh
all right forget this all right so now I
went on this one anyway so that oh I see
we went to this slide here ok so again
you see this dark red area which is
where the radiologist has circled it and
notice that the shape features do
cluster around the cancer ok and we will
try to use this observation later and of
course there are many false positives
here as you can see from this image now
one way to do this is to do these
spatial queries comparing the left and
right breast and that could reduce some
of the false positives if there's a
similar shape feature in the opposite
breast then probably not a cancer well
you know so if symmetric what we're
saying is the symmetry sort of a natural
structure so we're in this case you
might say well the asymmetry is a sign
of possible cancer again this is sort of
not everyone believes in a symmetry
right ok that's huh right ok because
this gentleman is a radiologist Roberts
so you know we've sort of you know that
isn't really the focus of the work is
this asymmetry which is 11 sort of test
of it so that's it huh all the shape
features just anything that you you
might look for something and it's just a
generic term ok just it could be Oh
could be like it could be eccentricity
certain moments of something or these
are natural waist we're saying ok the
shape feature could be what it really
looks like in terms of moments is a
characterization of shape so we just use
the shape feature as a general is a
general term but you would define shape
features a
Jake back a feature vector and you would
look for you know roundness or various
other things in there does that make
sense here these were these were done
these this is really from dr. this is a
an image that was given to us with with
them highlighter ready we didn't really
we didn't do that so that's why i can't
i can give you a shape feature as a
general term the way i would do it but
how whoever did these i do not really
know i'll talk a little bit about shape
features next but they're in a different
sort of in a different scale alright so
here you're really seeing so this is
symmetry aspect and what we're trying to
do now is at least on the next slide to
see what we could do with this grouping
of these small feature shape features
here now what happened you know it sort
of observed that the shape features seem
to cluster around the cancer so you can
look for for the shape feature you know
for shape features in certain clusters
or within certain distance of the
boundary of the boundary of the breasts
or things like that so what we could do
is look for clusters with a distance
query and here the image of the right
breast just shows the shape features and
some clusters now for example in this
case we're looking for clusters of three
shaped features within two millimeters
of each other and here it turns out you
require one feature among the strongest
ten the threshold was relative and you
could also combine strength of clustered
features in this case the results didn't
look that great in a sense that if you
did this clustering hear you found a
bunch of clusters but really only one of
them was was diagnosed as cancerous by
the radiologist one thing that I didn't
say before their one emphasis on one
emphasize is that different technologies
look for different type of features or
different characteristics in the image
so i'll look at ultrasound after this
and ultrasound i think is
war is what Jim was looking you were
looking for before in there I can tell
you the Sheep the shapes and things much
more you know they're you doing more fit
shape look looking for shapes whereas
here you're looking for features that
have been identified by someone and
you're looking for clusters or things
like that so here is another servant
mammogram image comparison where we're
trying to compare with the other breast
and you could reduce the number of false
positives this way if both breasts have
the same structures and then probably
natural this wasn't very helpful in this
case as I point out before our diagnosis
said that I mean the radiologist said
this was the cancers one these were not
when we look for these clusters in the
left breast we only found really these
three here so we didn't find as many as
we did in the right breast okay it
wasn't even the matching one so another
another way of characterizing these
things is to look at mammogram boundary
distance and here it's sort of based on
the observation that the spurious
clusters usually appear near the breast
boundary so what we're doing now is
incorporating the distance from the
breast boundary and you could say remove
all the clusters are within point five
millimeter of the of the breast boundary
and now this one seems to have worked in
a sense that it did eliminate all of
these were near the breast boundary
except for the one that was hit and
diagnosed as cancerous so at least it
eliminated the false positives and you
could try this across the entire
database so the goal in a sense is to
provide a database of these things and
possibly and allow a doctor or
radiologist to somehow say well I came
up with this case have I seen these
cases before and depending on the
technology on the imaging technology you
would look for different things and in
this particular case it's more of a
cluster II looking for clusters next
we'll go on to more shapes relevant to
really the type of things that we want
to do
so this is the case here and so that and
you can see right here and what we've
done I'm not we've done we sort of
showing you here you know what the
result was in a sense all right now
suppose you're looking at ultrasound in
this case that technology is the same as
a sonogram and where the images are made
with sound waves the darker areas the
cancer the outline is drawn in red in
case of sonograms the cancer is really
detected more by the shape by various
shapes around here so this is the
important aspect of detecting the
malignancy and in general if the shape
is rounded it tends to mean benign okay
where as you know these shaped features
are important here so it turns out that
another characteristic is lobule Asians
and it turns out I mean from studies
I've looked at I think the general
content conventions we have less than
three you're okay if you have more than
three then you could you know that's one
of the key that you're looking for and
another thing that happens is that
you're looking for speculations which
are sharp edges that's stand out of the
border that's another type of a feature
thing that you're looking for so here it
sort of answers Jim your question more
about shapes because much more I mean
just things are called shape features
where someone has diagnosed them has
characterized them before whereas here
you're really looking at a shape which
is what we're more interested in so in
this case again a smooth border
indicates benign and the lobby so you'll
see in the next one this one here you
have a speculation right here you can
see it you know we sort of highlighted
the thing here and our goal in a sense
is to is to provide a tool to look for
certain shape so in this case you could
draw this type of a shape and and then
look for it in the image or something
like that will show other things a
little later and so this is really that
the goal we certainly are not
air where we really done so far is
primarily build the database tool and
things like that and we have some
technology on pictorial query stuff
which I'll show next so this is the
example here the shape feature or other
shape features could be created to pick
out medically important features in this
case of speculation but you could be
looking for other features as well and
i'll show you the moment so you can
characterize a shape as a collection of
features to simplify search and focus on
medically relevant details so now what
I'm going to show you is sort of this
pictorial query specification technique
that we came up with with another for
another application and what our goal is
to do is to apply to use these type of
techniques in this medical environment
and what this application was originally
was to look for map symbols in other
words you have to get a map and you have
let a legend and the legend of the map
sort of gave you a training set for the
symbols you're looking for it now when I
say you're processing maps the
interesting thing is that if you look at
a rake a map you say it's hopeless to
find symbols there which is true our
maps are really constructed from
overlays in other words there are layers
for different symbols there's a tort
there's a layer first let's say tourist
symbol is a layer for roads a layer for
various type of symbols so you you know
what we were trying to do is really
process the layer of those particular
symbols anyway this is quite
illustrative here this is a screenshot
from one of our systems but in this case
there were you're looking for tourists
symbols and this is the library of
symbols okay so in this case what what
happens is I'm looking for you know this
sample query here it says retrieve all
images on a database have a feature with
a square in it let's say within six
minute millimeters of his features or
the wavy and doesn't have a feature of
an arrow in it this was an airfield
whatever it is within one millimeter of
this feature here there's an interesting
semantic
here because it turns out that some of
these you want bound to the same the
same feature and the way the query
system does that is I don't say it's
pretty elegant in the sense that here's
your library so I'm I'm saying i want
this symbol i take it out of here and
move it here another symbol i take from
here and in here now if my query
involves i want the same binding i just
take the symbol from here to here
instead of from here to here it's it
sounds trivial but this this involves
you know it's a very natural thing to
for someone who's doing say well i put
you know this symbol from here I wanted
this one but not its relation to this
one so you're able to build a pictorial
query tree which has arbitrary you know
combinations of ands ORS knots and all
that here we're just looking at a
snapshot of a couple of items in the
tree and that's the idea here now again
this language is not complete I'm not
saying anything about how great it is
but it just gives you a little bit of
power here and there are several things
you can do you can do with what we call
varying the contextual similarity and
the spatial similarity the contextual
similarity we have like four four
conditions here is I want exactly the
symbols in the query image to match the
database image no more no less in the
second one right here you're saying all
the all the symbols in the query image
must exist in the database image however
the database image could consist of
other symbols or things like that the
third one is the reverse it says any of
the symbols in the query image must
match but everything the database image
must match somebody in the query image
that's the reverse and the fourth one
just says just find one of the symbols
in the date in the you know just one of
the symbols in the query image must be
found in a database image in the spatial
similarity context we have that the
location has to be exactly the same of
all the features another one could say
within the same distance but you don't
care about the relative direction
between them the the the third one says
here the third one says any distance but
the same direction or within the same
distance but any direction or you don't
care at all about spatial constraints in
the way this thing is done for every one
of these little you know menu screen
shots like this all of the conditions
have to have to hold okay so the idea
really is but you could have a lot of
these little screens specifying the
query each just that each one everything
has to hold okay so you could have hands
it's quite a powerful language okay now
here's some examples of what we've done
and before I get the example what I want
to point out is that in the previous
example everything looked like it was
canned okay and this is one of the
problems with a lot of the image
database things in other words what
really what passes for an image database
is something which is pre classified in
other words somebody has gone in and
classified everything so then at the end
it's really not an image data it could
be any type of database it's just that
things have have terms you have attached
tags to the images and what we're trying
to do is to have to allow you both ways
so that means that you could do the
matching the way we showed before with
images that have been tagged by what
they are or you could also store them
what we call an abstraction mode
abstraction mode says that I've decided
on some feature vectors which GM asked
before like you know I our way roundness
a certain amount of way the genus or
some other things and that's my feature
vector and then I'm just going to match
feature vectors I'm not going to say
what I'm looking for but just and that
we call that an abstraction mode and in
this case we sort of test it out in this
application before we're looking for map
symbols there what we did is we took a
database of logos I mean it's not all
encompassing it maybe three four hundred
logos different shapes and you can see
there's a these are the
logo some of the logos here and what we
did was we use sort of a freehand tool
to draw the shapes because this really
effort would let us of the medical
application in a sense that our goal our
view is really for a radiologist to have
this type of a tool you know say well I
saw this type of a shape in this other
shape here can I find similar
configurations both spatially and these
type of things so here you can see we
have soared this horseshoe in a circle
or something like that and in this case
I just can't I didn't care about any
relation any distance and you can see it
fetched logos like this because you know
it was turned around this was also sort
of fit the mold okay here the circle is
not within the horseshoe but it's still
there okay all those are sort of
confidence levels that we had they're
just relative relative okay here we took
a simple triangular little feature and
you can see the ones some of the ones
that have found we didn't care there's
only one symbols there's really no no
point about relation or distance here is
the example where you sort of do the
logical aspect you're saying well I want
this but not this so we taken to you
bend with a circle but no triangle shape
so if you if you remember from before
you know there something here with a
triangle which one was that it's this
one here I think this is the one that
left as to what yeah so it sort of took
these as triangles and so it went out
now here is sort of interesting it gives
you the power of the normalization of
the features here you start looking for
this four-leaf clover or something like
that but it's all subject rotation you
know you normalize things with rotation
other things you can sort see the things
that found you know with a certain you
know level of acceptance but you see
even found as DDX here these sort of
patterns here they're arguably they're
not the same but with the normalization
everything it's not not bad to look for
it here we're looking with spatial query
type things
okay with so we're saying I have these
three bars the important thing here is
not the distance between them but their
shapes and their relative you know
relative positioning and it found this
Achilles here it wasn't bad here an
example where we relax things we didn't
care about the relation in the distance
we really were looking just for these
four shapes and of course it found a
much richer set okay another example is
I'm looking for these three dots here
and I'm saying I don't care about the
relation between them but the distance
the relative distance is important and
here you found these these type of
things here the reason the 0 and the 0
here because they got squished into a
syrup into a circle so that's where you
got this glow point here in this case
here we're more interested in the same
relation but any distance so the circle
had to be above these and now you know
it just retained this one here okay and
again we're looking at this story give
us the idea for the medical medical
things is that a lot you know these
features are hand you know these were
obviously not hand drawn because you
also have a library of feature of shapes
to do but I tried to show you here both
the use of from a library and that you
draw yourself okay so that's no that's
the goal and that sort of the things we
want to be doing and we start setting up
an infrastructure for doing it and you
know the very rudimentary things that we
have in this slide I sort of described
before the capabilities of this
Archimedes system that we're building
would be to do this shape based search
that we mentioned before that the
doctors can locate existing information
a specific shape of a tumor you would
search on the basis of existing
predefined shapes and again we said you
would draw them yourself and the spatial
search would be using the relative
positions in the and the directions
between them you could also use the
distance search for queries to look for
clusters that we saw in the mammogram
things there's ability to annotate the
images
and that would be just the associate
playing text with a particular image and
the idea here is really to have multiple
users being allowed to annotate the same
image at the same time and we also would
allow you to overlay image features
there's a virtual marker to highlight
and draw in an image and the ideas have
multiple overlays to capture analysis
from different doctors you could use it
to test their you know that's their
diagnosis or sort of comparison this
also enables you to do survey
teleradiology capability as well and if
there's also a text and range search
capability or at least whoops to be able
to do that so this is sort of a
screenshot of what we we built and down
here you would have you would show the
shapes for the query on it right here
let's say you can draw shapes over an
image for query in the top right so this
would be something like this here the
patient data notes you can this sort of
this window here you could do that the
image annotation can also be done here
on the top right and again the types of
queries sort of a menu of some limited
subset is here and if you run a query
the results will come up with these
thumbnails right here it says search
results so you would get some of these
search results here and you know that's
the idea here you could also force
enlarge this or explaining the user
interface whatever to it and you have to
said you have the ability to annotate
the images as we show right I don't it
doesn't come out that well but you can
see the different colors where somebody
when and annotated it and you have a
drawing tool you have the you know the
text nose at the bottom of type them in
the bottom the image and again these
multiple annotations could allow second
opinions it's also good for research so
this you know in conclusions you know
most medical databases allow query on
texts only our goal is to start allowing
queries on these days
basis by drawing or you know more of a
pictorial aspect also different types of
image content infant in conjunction with
text and we would also store in you know
multiple annotations feature sets as
well as allowing new feature sets to be
added and the storm in the database so
that other people could possibly use it
the previous slide was about my research
interest just to point out that i really
come in from the spatial side done a lot
of work on GIS representation of spatial
information as well as searching and we
sort of got into this with his map
things which then became generalized
just for the logos with the general
features and i sort of thought that'd be
a great idea to have to try to apply
this technology in a medical context so
there are a lot of tools you know many
of the tools that we use really come out
of the GIS work that we've done more on
spatial indexing and things like that
and some of this stuff actually runs on
this sand browser sans spatial database
that we build all right oh one more
thing I'm sorry thanks to a microsoft
research for sponsoring us on this and
there's a group of undergraduates here
it listed who actually worked and built
the sort of database thing which is
non-trivial all right yes
you have the accuracy I showed you that
we haven't started on the medical stuff
there so I can't really tell you at all
on that what i showed you accuracy was
on the logos and yeah again one of the
reasons that interesting about the
medical applications that nobody note
there's no answer okay and when I say no
answer there's you know whether it's
cancerous or not but it's it's sort of a
judgment thing I mean the goal of all
these diagnose event is to avoid the
invade the invasion or the biopsy of is
not necessary am i right I mean again
yep that's it yeah that that's the point
that's it so deep what is interesting
about these applications again I'm at
Maryland I'm really in the computer
vision lab and the one of the things in
computer vision is you the standards for
success or for doing things or an
inspection and other things are very
high okay I don't want to say that the
standards are low here but the bar here
is much lower so anything you do you
allow more in accuracy okay what you're
doing is providing information or get it
you know a radiology cannot possibly
look at everything you know all the
database all the images they've seen so
what this tool will try to give you is
the ability to go back and find things
that are similar and you know maybe it's
you know and actually you might even
learn from in other words hey there may
be some shape there are many things that
have this particular pattern which you
may not have noticed before it's just
this time you see this configuration so
we're really looking for and I'm not
it's not clear to me and in all honesty
whether this particular application is
the best suited one for the pictorials
very specification it could be another
one but you see what I'm saying I mean
you saw in the cluster in the cluster
with their mammograms is
sort in a way a certain way of looking
for for the feet you know for what is
cancer or not in the ultrasound you're
looking for different things some saying
we're trying to adapt this technology is
this technology of pictorial query
specification which is really where
we're going on to this domain where I
think you know it may work but one of
the things you need for success here is
really a much more you know more
interaction with the radiologist with
the people like that and one of the
things you find out is that the data is
a highly competitive business and and
getting people to let go of their data
is non-trivial okay and this is one of
the issues that you know problems that
we've we've had yah yah yah well okay
all right cubic one of the one of the
things about all you know most of the
methods for image for image kind they're
not on shape than anything they're
really on features like text up their
features like texture and color and
things like that the things that you
could quantify but you don't have the
shape and the relative position our work
is the only one that has really done the
shapes and really the relative position
the spatial things and I'm well aware of
those things and they're basically they
can't really get the content
specifically yeah oh yeah there's a lot
of trademark search yeah but they don't
really look for something next to
something within some they're looking
for a global thing that a texture a
color and things like that it's very
much I don't even say misleading but
it's yeah
and that was do you have enough
historical data so that those false
negatives that might have died we didn't
do many experiment any experiment at all
here I'm expecting that I want to make
that really clear i thought i did before
we're talking about a technology and
trying to apply it in a database and
building we have not gone to that stage
at all okay so the only experience you
saw here a little bit were there testing
of the query capability on some logo
database just to show you that actually
was able to retrieve some interesting
shapes based on those things and the
goal really is to possibly do it in the
medical okay yeah
I don't think from the point of view of
an animal
who is actually reading like this would
be very much use at least at this moment
where self-defined group for example
taking direction
and suppose that you sing the begining
that and i'm thirty percent
collect has truly actually part
open it's easy to lose that Oliver's
cancer but eventually you want those
images oh yeah sure I mean they're
coming here actually so you don't have
enough to vacuum and this is no matter
what you actually national easy to help
sort of the side that we try to do is
back so they put you the Sun and those
dogs have a problem to a game what is
tomorrow is not so
so the here I mean the features are
think you would describe certain i'm
looking for certain features certain
things and you would characterize me for
example on the on the examples where the
logos or those shapes you're saying okay
here's a measure around this here's a
measure of this these are your features
okay then you take these features you
cut your you construct a feature vector
for them you wait you know your you'll
construct some weights based on their
range so that you know their range of
values that's your feature right that's
what's done okay
well some people may go up in advance
what we're trying to give you the
ability to do here's on the fly okay
what most the time is done is they don't
even do they're just kept somebody to
say this is this you know don't measure
hey Jim Gray just said before on hubei
for things like that you say well here's
my texture here is this here is this and
that's your sort of your feature vector
what we're trying to do is character do
something with characterizing shape okay
the shape for example for us is a
contour it's a 48 for you descriptor
with like 32 coefficients we take the
Fourier descriptor with these 32
coefficients and we met it's a point in
a 32d space and that and that's it okay
so i give you an example but our what
our current descriptors of the contour
of the shape that's what's done in these
particular thing in other examples with
the with the symbols like the hotel
symbols and things like that we actually
use roundness and other features okay
another thing that we did here an
example is on features you ask well on
the examples with the logos we have
somewhere you have sort of known shapes
you have squares you have other things
you could describe those very shapes egg
the lip says as circles squares other
things and now what r splines okay or
polygons okay now what you're doing now
is every shape you're going to just you
have a program that decides what's the
base you know what's the best
representation as a polygon or as a
spline or something like that once you
do that that's your feature descriptor
and what we do is we normalize to get
you know the relative sizes and the idea
here was to give you an example of what
you can derive from it and the whole
thing you know is based on the premise
that well this might be useful in
medicine and that's the thing it's it's
a 10 you know it's I don't say it's not
we're not saying hey we have the tool
you know it's going to work for it no
the idea is to say here you might have
this tool you might be able to use it to
actually look at
old data in other words there is data
about whether it was a cancer was not
and people still learn from experience
okay so what this is a way of harvesting
the old experience a way of clearing on
it decides the eyeballs because the
eyeballs can't really find the
similarity so this is a substitute
eyeball in a sense that's what it is so
you know that's that's the goal I think